find the mean median and mode of the
following sets of numbers and they give
us the numbers right over here so if
someone just says the mean they're
really referring to what we typically in
an everyday language call the average
sometimes it's called the arithmetic
mean because you'll learn that there's
other ways of actually calculating a
mean but it's really you just sum up all
the numbers and you divide by the
numbers there are and so it's one way of
measuring the central tendency or you
know the average I guess we could say so
this is our mean we want to average 23
plus 29 over to some 23 plus 29 plus 20
plus 32 plus 23 plus 21 plus 33 plus 25
and then divide that by the number of
numbers so have one two three four five
six seven eight numbers so you want to
divide that by eight so let's figure out
what that actually is actually I'll just
get the calculator out for this part I
could do it by hand but let's save some
time over here so we have 23 plus 29
plus 20 plus 20 plus 32 plus 23 plus 21
plus 33 plus 25 so the sum of all the
numbers is 206 and then we want to
divide 206 by 8 so if I say 206 divided
by 8 gets us 25 point seven five so the
mean is equal to 25 point seven five so
this is one way to kind of measure the
center the central tendency another way
is with the median and this is to pick
out the middle number the median and to
figure out the median what we want to do
is order these numbers from least to
greatest so it looks like the smallest
number here is 20 20 then the next one
is 21 21 then we go there's no 22 here
there's let's see there's two 23 is 23
and a 23 so 23 and a 23 and no 24s there
is a 25
twenty-five there's no 26 27 28 there is
a 29 29 then you have your 32 32 and
then you have your 33 33 so what's the
middle number now that we've ordered it
so we have one two three four five six
seven eight numbers we already knew that
and so there's actually going to be two
middles if you have two if you have an
even number there's actually two numbers
that kind of qualify for the close to
the middle and to actually get the
median we're going to average them so
twenty-three will be one of them that by
itself can't be the median because
there's three less than it and there's
four greater than it and 25 by itself
can't be the median because there's
three larger than it and four or less
than it so what we do is we take the
mean of these two numbers and we pick
that as the median so if you take 23
plus 25 divided by two that's 48 over 2
which is equal to 24 so even though 24
isn't one of these numbers the median is
24 so this is the middle number so once
again this is one way of thinking about
central tendency if you wanted a number
that could somehow represent in the
middle and I'm gonna be clear there's no
one way of doing it this is one way of
measuring the middle the middle let me
put that in quotes the middle if you had
to represent this data with one number
and this is another way of representing
the middle then finally we can think
about the mode and the mode is just the
number that shows up the most in this
data set and all of these numbers show
up once except we have the 23 it shows
up twice and so 20 since because 23
shows up the most it shows up twice
every other number only shows up once 23
23 is our mode